Now, we're beginning January the 4th, 1924, and this is Volume 16.
So this is the words of Jesus in the garden, not my will, but yours be done.
This has to be our motto.
Okay.
So this is a very important message.
I was thinking about the words of Jesus in the garden when he said, "Father, if it be
possible, let this chalice pass from me, but not my will, but yours be done."
And my sweet Jesus, moving in my interior, told me, "My daughter, do you think it was
because of the chalice of my passion that I said to the father, 'Father, if it is possible,
let this chalice pass from me.'
The vast majority of scholars say, 'Yes, he was afraid to die.'
Which means, of course, they're not really accepting his divinity as well as his humanity.
Not at all, Jesus said, "It was the chalice of the human will which contained such bitterness
and such fullness of vices that my human will united with the divine felt such repugnance,
terror, and fright as to cry out, 'Father, if it be possible, let this chalice pass from
me.'
How ugly is the human will without the divine will?
Which almost as within a chalice enclosed itself in each creature.
There's no evil in the generations of which it is not the origin, that's the human will.
The human will is not the origin of which the human will is not the origin, the seed and
the found.
Now what Jesus is saying here is that it was the chalice of the human will in rebellion
to the divine will that made him pray like this.
But you have to go to the sixth hour of the passion.
And when you go to the sixth hour of the passion you have Jesus agonizing in the garden and
you have him saying three times to the Father, 'Not my will, but thine be done.'
Now Louisa is going to give you a different reason there for this prayer than she's giving
you here because in the sixth hour of the passion Jesus says that the thing that is costing
him the most is that souls who would rebel against the divine will would be lost.
Now it's still the human will against the divine but it's a completely different aspect
of the problem and this is where when we're looking at these writings we have to compare
what was said in one place with another so that we're seeing a bigger picture.
And Jesus said, 'And seeing myself covered with all of these evils produced by the human
will before the sanctity of my will, I felt myself dying.'
Now Louisa does describe him that way in the garden of Gethsemane.
And indeed I would have died if the divinity had not sustained me.
Okay, now the thing that strikes me there is that the kingdom of the divine will is really
established here in Gethsemane where he's on behalf of the whole human race says not
my will but thine be done.
And we have to enter into that at such a level that it actually represents where I'm at in
my life that my attitude to God is not my will but thine be done.
And if we are sincere about that the Lord will give you exercise to see is it really
true.
What I mean by that is if you say Lord not my will but thine be done you'll find people
walking over your will.
You'll find people going contrary to your will and the exercise is yes I really mean
it not my will but thine be done and what I find in my life anyway is that every now
and then the Lord gives you a whole space of things where the lesson every single time
is not my will but thine be done.
I had an entire morning of it very very recently where everything went against me absolutely
everything I tried to do.
And I just said not my will but thine not my will but thine it was absolutely everything
and then the whole thing stopped.
And I realized it was an exercise sometimes we don't register that what is happening to
us is an exercise from above and that if we give the response that the Lord is looking
for that the need for the exercise is then taken away.
In other words the teacher says okay they got it they got the message.
So we have to make absolutely sure that my attitude to God is permanently not my will
but thine be done.
And if your will isn't crossed please come back and tell the rest of us how you manage.
But Jesus said do you know why I added and as many as three times not my will but thine
be done.
I felt upon myself all the wills of creatures united together he's saying it on our behalf.
He didn't have to say it on his behalf he's saying it on our behalf and we're all incorporated
into him.
I felt he said all of their evils and in the name of all I cried out to the father may
the human will be done on earth no more.
Now if you know the level of crisis that's in the earth today one of the things that
we have to do is enter into the divine will and unite with the divine will and in the
name of the human race say not my will but thine be done.
Not my will.
So you're like Jesus you're saying it also on behalf of everybody else not just on your
own behalf because it's one thing to say it for yourself it's quite another matter to
say it for everybody else.
So may the human will be done on earth no more only the divine.
May the human will be banished and may the divine will reign.
So that's a prayer we've got to start doing frequently.
Particularly now when there's an enormous amount of rebellion against God around.
So even from that time and I wanted to do this at the very beginning of my passion because
the calling upon earth of the fiat volunteers to on earth as it is in heaven was the thing
that interested me the most the most important one.
So here he's saying that at the very beginning of his passion he's calling upon the era
of the fulfillment of the our father he was the one who gave us the prayer of the our
father that the most important thing was to honor God and to do God's will.
So here he's crying out for it to actually be fulfilled and I think we need to cry out
for it to be fulfilled on a daily basis as well.
We need to cry out on a daily basis for it to be fulfilled.
So this was the most important thing for me Jesus said I myself said in the name of all
you see all our prayers in the divine will are in the name of all non maya voluntas said
to a fiat not my will but thine.
From that time I constituted the era of the fiat voluntas to honor that's why you have
to put a VIP on this particular text because if people ask you what was the moment in which
he declared the kingdom of the divine will open it's at this moment.
When he says to God the father not my will but thine be done and he's saying it on behalf
of everybody else so he now wants the human will on earth to cease.
So from that time I constituted the era of the fiat balances to honor and by saying
it as many as three times in the first one what this I prayed for the divine will to
be done on earth as it is in heaven.
In the second one I made the divine will descend and in the third one I constituted the divine
will ruler and dominator and in saying not my will but thine be done I intended to empty
the creatures of their wills and to fill them with the divine.
So he's speaking to the father on our behalf and he's constituting the new era to come
into existence so his own prayer will be fulfilled okay.
So before dying since I had only a few hours left I wanted to negotiate with my celestial
father my primary purpose for which I came on the earth that the divine will might take
its first place of honor in the creature now notice its first place first place.
This has been the first act of man to withdraw from the divine will and therefore it was
our first offense.
Now here he is in the very first stage of the passion and he's dealing with it so first
things first so what is the most important thing dealing with the human will.
So I want to give you Sam one oh six verse twenty three Jesus is standing in the breach
as Moses did before him between God's justice and our sinfulness and he's praying the new
situation into existence a Sam one oh six verse twenty three and he said all other evils
are in the secondary order now why are they in the secondary order it's because they all
follow the rebellion of the human will if the human will didn't rebel the other evils
wouldn't show up and therefore it's dealing with the human will has got to be done first
therefore first I had to accomplish the purpose of the fear polontas to honor as it is in
heaven to then form the redemption with my pains in fact redemption itself is in the
secondary order why is that because if the human will hadn't rebelled redemption wouldn't
have been needed it is always my will that has prime primacy in all things that's why
I've been saying for years that our motto has got to be not my will but thine be done
and even though it was the effects of the fruits of redemption that could be seen it
was by virtue of this contact which I made with my divine father that his fiat was to
come and reign upon the earth realizing the true purpose for the creation of man which
was to do God's will I think the Pentecatechism said it very well to know love and serve God
on the earth and be with him forever we need to bring it back you know we will never improve
on the answers that were in the Pentecatechism because they were so succinct and theologically
profound absolutely fantastic so this was the true purpose of the creation of man and
the primary purpose for which I came on the earth that is to deal with the rebellion
of the human will and to restore the divine will to the earth and that man received the
fruits of the redemption otherwise my wisdom would have lacked order now one of the things
is very very clear and Louise's writings is the divine order of God everything has got
to be in order if the beginning of evil was man's will it was man's will that I was to
reorder look at the words and restore reorder because it's out of order restore to the divine
will reuniting the divine will and the human will and even though the fruits of redemption
could be seen first this says nothing my will is like a king who though he is first among
all he arrives last being preceded for his honor and decorum by his peoples his armies
his ministers his princes and his royal court now what Jesus is describing there is a Roman
triumphal procession where all all the army and all everything goes before the triumphor
the triumphor is actually last okay so it's the triumphal procession and so the fruits
of redemption were needed first so that the height of the majesty of my will now notice
the height as one of the words it's that's consistent in louisa for supreme as the supreme
majesty of God and when she says that the height of the blessed mother she's talking
about the supreme holiness of the blessed mother the height and it's just that nowadays we
use the word supreme more than height so that the height or the supremacy of the majesty
of my will might find the royal court the peoples the armies and the ministers in other words
it takes time for this procession to pass by so he's going to bring in two words corresponding
to each other contract covenant okay do you know who was the first one to cry out together
with me not my will but thine be done it was my little newborn of my will my little daughter
who felt such repugnance and fright at her will that trembling she'd clung to me and
cried out with me father if it is possible let the chalice of my will pass from me can
I suggest you take that off the page put it on a little card and put it somewhere where
you're going to see it every single day that's the most wonderful prayer to pray to the Lord
father if it be possible let the chalice of my will because my will is the source of all
my problems let the chalice of my will pass from me and crying you added with me not my
will but thine be done and yes you were together with me in that first contract with the celestial
father because at least one creature was needed in order to validate the contract in other words
he needed he always needs at least one person representing humanity now I always translate
that into he needs one drop of water in his wine and that little drop of water in the wine that I
look at every day at mass I think it's so important we just don't realize the importance of it that's
us our tiny participation okay I needed one creature at least in order to validate the contract
somebody on the earth had to say yes so the more of us who are saying yes the more powerful it is
in history otherwise to whom would I give it to whom would I entrusted and in order to render the
custody of the contract more secure I gave you all the fruits of my passion as a gift he sang to
Louisa now up to this moment the only thing we knew was that only one person had experienced all the
fruits of the of the passion and all the fruits of redemption and that was our blessed mother but
Louisa has reached such height herself in her relationship with God that this is what Jesus is
saying now so the commentary that I have in my margin is wow I don't think it requires anything
else and he said I lined them up around you like a formidable army which while forming the royal
courtage of my will wages a fierce war against your will now all the tussles that you see between
Jesus and Louisa in these writings it's the divine will making absolutely certain her human will
isn't going to shift even remotely it's absolutely fantastic and therefore in our efforts to live
the divine will the Lord is saying to us he has to love us more than we love ourselves
and so if our will is shifting away from him then he has to do something to make you come back and
he calls it waging war on you you find that interesting now war isn't comfortable therefore
courage in the state that you are in in other words you're called to be a hero dismiss the thought
that I may leave you she's always accusing him of that it would be detrimental to my will why
because the divine will need somebody on the earth to sign the contract okay since I keep the
contract of my will deposited in you so remain at peace it is my will that tests you wanting only
to purge you and to destroy even the shadow of your will okay it's my will that tests you for
some reason I have Exodus 25 22 there and I forget why I put it there Exodus 25 22 it's my will
that tests you wanting only to purge you and to destroy even the shadow of your will because the
more our will is literally put aside the more the plan that the divine will has for the human race
on earth can be fulfilled the more of us who actually make this surrender so in all peace continue
your flight in my volition and be concerned with nothing Colossians 3 15 and Philippians 4 7 the
peace that passes all understanding your Jesus will make it so that everything which may happen
inside and outside of you will make my will stand out even more and will expand within you
the boundaries of my will in your human will so with this surrender if we actually leave it to him
you hear him saying frequently to Louisa Louisa let me do let me do just just give me a bit of
freedom to do this and if we let him do it then he expands his divine will in us he expands our
soul to be able to take what he's offering to us and everything will be accomplished so it's all
in the surrender I myself will keep the pace in your interior that I may direct everything in you
according to my will now that sent that part of the sentence there that I may direct everything
is Deuteronomy 32 12 the Lord alone was his guide I occupied myself with nothing but the will of
the Father alone and since all things are in his will I occupied myself with everything
I'm just going to give you two examples here out of many John 5 30 and John 8 29 5 30 and 8 29
I only do what my father tells me to do I only say what my father tells me to say
the father and I are one and all the rest of it John's gospel is great for illustrating that
and if I taught only one prayer it was no other than this that the divine will would be done on
earth as it is in heaven but it was the prayer that enclosed everything because it was the human
will that destroyed God's plan so the divine will taking over will restore God's plan so I did not
move if not around the Supreme will the whole of John's gospel attest to that my words my pains my
works my heart beats were filled with the celestial will so so I want you to do now if you put that
into ordinary English I want the same from you and I think you need to color that one if you
color things because the Lord is saying this is what I want from you you must go around in the
divine will so much as to let yourself be burned by the eternal breath of the fire of my will
now the breath of God is Ruach Adonai as the spirit of God the Ruach Adonai
and the fire of the divine will Deuteronomy 4 24 and Hebrews 12 29 our God is a consuming fire
now you know from many of the texts that we've done already that louisa does experience this
consuming fire she even says I feel I'm being consumed inside without really knowing what it is
but in the hours of the passion you hear her praying let your fire burn me up yeah and you're
talking about the human will there okay so January the 14th 1924 so this is the stripping and
discouraging of Jesus what you find in louisa's writings is that you will get a group of messages
all around the same subject so louisa said I was accompanying the mystery of the scourging
I was sympathizing with my sweet Jesus when he saw himself so confused in the midst of his enemies
now you have to ask yourself why is the word confused put there because when we say somebody
is confused we were saying they don't get it okay that's not what she's saying okay so watch out
for this now stripped of his garments under a storm of blows so my beloved Jesus coming out of my
interior in the state that he was in when he was scourged told me my daughter do you want to know
why I was stripped when I was scourged now nothing happened to him that the divine will
did not ordain and therefore every single emotion of the passion has incredible treasure
for us understanding who Jesus is and how he relates to us and the meaning of the whole of
redemption okay so that's what he's going to talk about so why did I let it happen
in each mystery of my passion first I occupied myself with joining the split between the human
will and the divine so that's number one all the time and then with the offenses which this split
produced so first of all it's the split between the human and the divine then the sins that came
out of that when man in Eden broke the bonds of the union between the supreme will and his will
he stripped himself of the royal garments of my will
and he clothed himself with the miserable rags of his will so he became weak
incontinent impotent for doing any good okay so that is the description of the prodigal son
in Luke 15 verses 13 to 17 miserable incontinent impotent in doing any good and reducing himself
to an absolute misery you also have Mark chapter 5 verses 1 to 6 Mark chapter 5 verses 1 to 6
and verse 15 now that's the demoniac who reduces himself to an absolute wreck because of the
destructive are you all right Luke 15 verses 13 to 17 and Mark 5 verses 1 to 6 and verse 15
now in both cases for the demoniac and for the prodigal son you are told that when they returned
to the father they were clothed okay I want to take you back to Genesis and when you're told in
Genesis chapter 2 that man was created you're told he was not wearing clothes as we wear clothes
but he was not naked when he rebels against the will of God in chapter 3 you are then told
that man is naked so in the bible and in these writings which speaks in this exact same language
as you have in the bible nakedness has to do with the loss of grace it's nothing to do with physical
clothes it's to do with the loss of grace now there's an absolutely extraordinary text at the
other end of the bible I've taken you from Genesis to Revelation Revelation 16 16
you're told happy is the man who has stayed awake and has not taken off his clothes
so that he does not go out naked to expose his shame now I'm quite sure John is not speaking
about streaking what John is saying is you are in the final chastisement make sure that the garment
of grace that was given to you in baptism is still on because without your garment of grace
you are going to a terrible destiny so I just want you to hear in these writings and in the bible
that clothing is grace nakedness is exposure to evil and a person who is naked has no grace
is totally exposed to the attacks of the evil one okay so there you have the the the prodigal son
and and the demoniac and all the rest of it so let's come to the next point then my will was a
sweet enchantment for him so this is a an attraction that god is continuously giving to the human race
which kept him absorbed within a most pure light which made him know nothing but his god now this
is pre fall this is genuine innocence you don't know evil okay you see no evil you hear no evil
and you speak no evil so he knew nothing but his god from whom he had come and to gave him nothing
but innumerable happiness we would say much happiness because my book has happiness s which is not
english so you can say innumerable happiness s if you're not talking english god gave him
plenty of happiness okay and he was so absorbed in the generosity of his god to him i'm trying to
put english on this is that okay that he would not give a talk to himself so here's the human will
now married to the divine will now you know that when when the snake appeared at the snake said
but you don't know everything you don't know evil god's keeping an awful lot away from you and god
is painted as the big beddy okay oh how happy man was and how the divinity delighted in giving him
so many particles of his being now that's the bit you color what was it that the lord was giving
the man god can only give himself and there's only one model and that's god himself so god was
giving him so many particles of his own being for as many as the creature can receive in order to
make him similar to himself so there's you have your genesis one 27 he is made in the image of god
as god shares particles of his own being so as soon as he broke the union with our will he lost
the royal garment now for us that's the garment of baptism okay but the context in which we're
reading here it's that he lost the divine will that's the biggest garment of all
he lost the enchantment he lost the light and he lost the happiness he looked at himself
without the light of my will and in looking at himself without the enchantment that kept him
absorbed he came to know himself that means in a carnal manner he felt ashamed and he became
afraid of god sin makes us afraid of god because it automatically produces in us the
understanding that we will face judgment okay so that's genesis 310
and this was such that his very nature felt the sad effects of this he felt the cold
and he felt his nakedness and he felt the vital need to cover himself this is all the result of
this so-called enlightenment notice i say so-called just as our will kept him within the port of
immense happiness knock out the es so did his will put him in the port of miseries so you've been
shown clearly here the human will is the source of misery and pain and sin and death and hell
our will was everything for man and in our will he found everything it was right that having come
out of us and living in our will as our tender child that he would live of the divine will
so all his acts would be in the divine order and this will was to make up for everything that he
needed now you hear jesus saying that to louise all the time about her relationship with him
that he will give her everything she needs therefore as man wanted to live of his own will
he became needy of everything that that is actually something you should underline
because the human will does not have the power to make up for all his needs
in fact one of the most basic realities in the world today and i go to illustrate it for you
is that people have an ache in the depths of their being
and this ache they can't put a name on it and it sort of reads i want something and i don't know
what i want i'm sure you've felt it haven't you and they'll do anything to try and drown this need
they'll drink it off and then when they get sober again it's still there they'll go out and have
a nice meal with friends and when they've spent the money and the friends and they come home
in the middle of the night it's back because it is the soul crying out for god that's actually
what it is that desperate need and adam didn't know that need until he had given up the divine
will and he was back depending on himself let me give you a very very very simple example because
we're trying to help each other to give examples aren't we um a child in the middle of the family
has all the needs met and the parents take care of everything let the child wander out onto the
street by itself and in no time at all its name is need i know of a certain person
whose little son at the age of six decided he was leaving home he'd had enough so everybody was
deficient and he was gone and the mother just happened to be rather wise and she said that's
fine you know i mean you're a man you can go and when you got to the edge of the garden she said
by the way did you take your pyjamas oh no that was a bit awkward you hadn't thought of that she said
how are you going to manage tonight oh that that worries him a little bit and then she said um
have you got any money and he said money she said yeah out there in the big bad world you have to pay
for the food you eat and the anything you drink and if you want to stay in anybody else's house
you don't have to pay for it she was talked to a six-year-old and she went on like this for about
five or ten minutes and then the fella said to her it's too complicated i'll go back
I just think it's a really nice illustration that you leave the comfort and the wonder of
that relationship that supplies all your needs and your name becomes need that is what Jesus
is saying here do you see that you don't have to give sophisticated examples life is full of
illustrations of what the lord is saying here and i love that the little fella saying no it's too
complicated i'll go back so he decided to put up with him he's wonderful uh so now that man has
broken from the will of god he wanted to live his own will so he became need instead of just
saying needy of everything i would just say he he became need yeah have you ever gone to the lord
and said i am need try it but i mean it has to be the truth because if you try it i did he said i
am plenty i said i am i am a sinner he said i am your savior i am hungry he said i am your food
i'm trying to think of things then so that the the dialogue would continue and every time i said
something he had the solution to it he is our happiness our peace our everything okay but we're
need by ourselves um the human will does not have the power to make up for all our needs nor does it
contain the fount of good within itself there's your john 15 5 without me you can do nothing
the good the source of good is not in us it's in god so man was forced to procure for himself
with hardship the necessary things of life do you see then what it means not to be united with my will
oh if all knew the divine will they would have one yearning and that would be that my will would
come to rain upon the earth so had Adam not withdrawn from the divine will his nature also would have
had no need of clothing is that interesting and his nature would have had the integrity
and the health and absolutely everything it was created in he would not have felt ashamed of his
nakedness nor would he have been subject to suffering cold heat hunger and weakness but these
natural things were almost nothing rather they were symbols of the great good that his soul had
lost like that's a wonderful piece isn't it so so who's going to pay for getting the divine
clothing given back to us therefore my daughter before being tied to the pillar to be scourged
I wanted to be stripped in order to suffer and repair for the nakedness of man
when he stripped himself of the royal garment of my will I felt such confusion and pain within me
in seeing myself stripped in the midst of enemies who are mocking me that I cried over the nakedness
of man and I offered my nakedness to this celestial father so that man might be clothed once again
with the royal garment of my will so now you see the confusion is explained he had to take on all
the the reaction that man experienced in breaking with the divine will and he had to experience it
so for him as the son of god it must have been a brutal experience in itself
and as ransom so that this would not be denied to me I offered my blood my flesh torn to shreds
and I let myself be stripped not only of my garments but also of my skin so
louisa describes him in the hours of the passion as like a skinned lamb which of course is an exact
description of what Isaiah said he would be
but also my skin to be able to pay the price and to satisfy for the crime of this nakedness of man
I poured out so much blood in this mystery that in no other did I pour out so much
isn't that interesting so much as to be enough to cover him with the second garment the garment
of blood now put their revelation 714 where you will read that in the end that the saints will be
washed white in the blood of the lamb washed white in the blood of the lamb and before you get to the
end that washing white in the blood of the lamb is in the sacrament of penance okay so a garment
of blood so as to cover him again and then warm him and wash him to dispose him to receive
the royal garment of my will on hearing this louisa was surprised and she said my beloved Jesus
how can it be possible that because he withdrew from your will man felt the need to clothe himself
was ashamed and afraid and so on but then you always did the will of the celestial father watch
this she never let them off with anything not anything you did the will of the celestial father
you were one with him and your mother never knew her own will and yet the two of you needed clothing
and food and you needed you never felt and you felt the cold and the heat of course Jesus has to
say to your mind if the two of us were naked in our society don't you think we'd be strong from
the first tree he had to adapt to the society he came to but he tells her much more delicately
than i've said it too and Jesus added yet my daughter it is precisely so if man felt ashamed
of his nakedness and was subject to many natural miseries it was precisely because he lost to the
sweet enchantment of my will and even though it was his soul that did the evil not his body
the body however indirectly was as though an accomplice with the wicked will of man
and so his nature remained as though profaned by the bad will of man so the body had to
suffer from the soul therefore both the soul and the body had to feel the pain of the evil that was
committed as for me indeed i always did the supreme will but i did not come to find man innocent
that's Romans five eight i did not come to find a man before sin rather i came to find a sinful man
with all of his miseries and so i had to associate myself with men taking upon myself all of their
evils and subjecting myself to all the necessities of life as if i were one of them okay now he's
doing that also to redo the whole of humanity but he's just not covering the subject of redoing
the whole of humanity here want to give you one Corinthians 9 22 i make myself all things for all
men hoping to redeem them however in me there was this tragedy if i wanted i would need nothing
either clothing or food or anything else but i did not want to make use of it out of love for man
i wanted to sacrifice myself and everything even in the most innocent things created by me
in order to prove my ardent love for him now that's taught eloquently in volumes one to four
trying to get us to do the same thing that we would sacrifice in order to bring souls to him
and i also want to give you one Corinthians 8 1 Corinthians 8 verses 7 to 13 even more this served
to intercede with my heavenly father that out of regard for me and from my completely sacrificed
will to him that he would give back to man the royal garment of his will so every single detail
in the life of Jesus is making reparation for all the results of the fall and pleading for
the divine will to be given back to us i think that's beautiful passages isn't it
so in January the 20th we're naturally enough talking about the divine will and i was in the
hard state of my usual privations of my beloved good louisa said and i felt immersed in bitterness
knock out the two words letters at the end without the one who alone makes the sun the warmth the
smile the happiness arise in my poor soul now louisa is suffering because it seems to her
that the person who is the source of all our happiness and everything else is being removed
so she's actually illustrating the happiness that comes from living in the divine will without him
it's always nighttime now you see the sinner is like that without the divine will it's always
night i remained numb with the cold of his privation and i am unhappy so she's actually experiencing
what adam experienced but on a completely different level that without him this is how i am
with him i'm totally happy so i was feeling oppressed in my sweet jesus moving in my interior
the kingdom of god is within you so that's luke 17 21 he said my daughter courage do not leave
yourself prey to oppression this is very important and i want to give you two karantians two 11
two karantians two 11 and i want to give you effigions for 27
okay you're feeling the bitterness of the privation but if you let us in on you yourself
emotionally you're going to allow oppression and guess who's going to sit on it okay always
looking for an opportunity so you've got to push this oppression out if you knew how much i suffer
in seeing you suffer because the two of them are one aren't they uh i suffer so much that in order
not to see you suffer so much i put you to sleep uh but i remain close to you and i don't leave you
and while you sleep i do for you what we should be doing together i think that's absolutely beautiful
listen just okay now if i was having to illustrate this in a little seminar i would say think of a
daddy sitting on the bedside and the child is sleeping and the daddy has helped the child to
sleep with a little bit of medication because the child is going through a rough time and what
you're looking at is tenderness what you're looking at is love what you're looking at is someone
really caring about the other okay so he says that's what i do for you uh so while you sleep i do for
you uh what we should be doing together and uh if we were awake because it's not you who wants
to sleep it is i who want it and this is why i make up for you so i want to give you two things there
one is footprints and the other is sam one two seven verse two
and the lord is my light and my salvation what should i fear okay um do you see how much i love
you jesus said if you knew how much i suffer when i see you wake up visiting because you have not
perceived that i was close to you uh since i myself have put you to sleep in the torment of my
privation isn't that interesting uh it's true that you suffer i too suffer but it is the bond of my
will that flows in you also in this and clasping you more renders our union more stable he's saying
to her the privation is also part of the divine will uh the the scripture says the just man lives
by faith okay that only came to me now so i don't have the reference um and so louisa has to
experience her being as a creature and him in his heaven if i can put it that way but that doesn't
take away from the fact that you you are one with him so whether you are praying in coldness or
lukewarmness or anything else it doesn't change the reality that he's there and you're there and the
two of you are actually in union it just simply means that emotionally you feel different and
we have to be careful not to let the emotions take over and so therefore i want you to have courage
and remember that you are my little boat now my little boat have you got the reference for that
no in your book the reference for that is february the fourth 1921 volume 13
now you can look that up yourself louisa is the lord's little boat february the fourth 1921
volume 13 you are my little boat so she is the little boat sailing on the sea of the divine will
okay um now st. teres also spoke of herself as a little boat and that the the holy spirit with
the sails bringing this little boat through the sea of life um so you are my little boat in my will
and the divine will is not a sea of water which has its ports and shores where boats ships and
passengers make their stops they take rest they give themselves to amusements and many passengers
do not even return to cross the sea again and the sea of my will is a sea of light
it is a sea of fire without a port and without any shore now louisa will get eloquent on this when
you get up into the volume 20s therefore there are no stops from my little boat she must cross it
continuously but with such speed as to enclose the whole of the endless eternity in each one of
your heartbeats and acts in such a way as to connect them to the eternal heartbeat and act
which is the heartbeat of each and every one of course you can't do that except in the divine will
and you crossing over all will do the round of eternity in each heartbeat of yours you will take
everything and will bring us all that comes from the divinity in order for it to give and to receive
but while it gives it does not receive and my little boat has the task to cross the immense
sea of my will in order to requite us for everything that comes from us that's our response now in
rounds and thanksgiving and everything else so if you oppress yourself you will lose the attentiveness
of the round and the sea of my will not feeling agitated by the speedy rounds of my little boat
will burn you more now notice the sea needs to be agitated by the little rounds in other words
it's like if you throw a stone into a lake you're going to get these wonderful tiny little waves
okay and the Lord is saying you must touch the divine will with your action with your movement
just as the little stone touches the the water and and if you don't do it you'll burn more now
if you were with me for studying Jeremiah Jeremiah was quite clear about that at one stage he didn't
want to give God's messages anymore because he was given bad news all the time and they were giving
him a hard time and then he said but when I tried to keep it in he said the word burned in my soul
and the only way to release it was to actually give it okay you will burn more and you will
fidget more because of my privation but if you keep going around you will be like the sweet little
breeze which while bringing refreshment to our fire will serve you to sweeten the torment you
suffer because of my privation now Jeremiah 15 18 said to the Lord my suffering is continual
and that was why he was tempted not to say everything now louisa has been grossly tempted not to say
everything and you meet that very particularly in the first ten volumes that she really doesn't
want to say everything and she discovers that things don't improve when you don't say everything
so january the 23rd are the three fiats okay I was abandoning all of myself in the holy will of
God and I thought to myself the Fiat formed the whole universe and in the Fiat the divinity made
display of its love and this display was made towards man exposing it in each created thing
in such a way that impressed in each created thing one can see that Fiat with such great mastery
power and harmony was released from the divine bosom towards the creature now the sams are full
of rounds of creation you know that don't you so I suggest that you could put in there the last
five sams they're all sams of praise to God they're all the halal that's praise
praising God for his redemption I call it the rounds of enough redemption creation I call it
the rounds of creation the last five they're wonderful so if you get tired doing your own rounds try
them they're actually very wonderful so the Fiat formed the redemption here's the second Fiat
so much so that in each thing which the eternal word did the Fiat is present and surrounded them
like a crown it gives them life so the creating Fiat and the redeeming Fiat are braided together
she loves the word braided because she does embroidery and one echoes within the other forming one single
Fiat and there's no created act which my sweet Jesus did not braid with the quite of his Fiat
now my adored Jesus has told me many times that the third Fiat is needed so that the works of creation
and redemption may be completed so how will this be done who will form so many Fiat's as to braid
the creating Fiat and the redeeming Fiat while I was thinking of this my adorable Jesus moving in
my interior which is Luke 17 21 my daughter he said if the supreme majesty released so much love
towards mankind in all the things created in the omnipotent Fiat it was right that I his son in his
in the same Fiat would do as many acts to requite him for his love braiding his Fiat with mine now
notice as many acts the creator and the redeemer they do the same number of acts they cover everything
okay so braiding his Fiat that creation with mine which is redemption so that another Fiat
human and divine which of course is Jesus might rise from the earth to exchange the kiss with his
Fiat be braided with it and substitute for the return of love of all creatures so Jesus does the
same number of acts as as done in the creating Fiat he substitutes for all the response that
should be coming back from the earth so he is speaking not just in his own name but in the name
of everyone from Adam to Zachary A to Z so until I came upon the earth the Fiat which was spread
throughout creation was by itself but as I came it was no longer alone indeed my first task was
that of forming as many acts in the eternal Fiat for as many acts as my father had done in creation
so with my Fiat the creating Fiat had its most harmonious company okay but we have to have a
Trinity everything has to be done in threes okay now the Fiat does not want to remain in two it
once a third let me give you this quick before we even read it the bride has to say yes
Luisa is representing the bride okay and when you go to the the end of the book of revelation
you're going to hear just before his return the spirit and the bride say come
so that means the divine will is really on the earth okay so the spirit and the bride
must say yes that's revelation 22 17 let's just put it in some kind of perspective for you
so the Fiat does not want to remain in two it wants a third one it wants to be in three
and this third Fiat is you you're the one that must do it in other words Luisa is the drop of
water representing all of us this is why many times I have drawn you outside of yourself and
I've placed you within that very creating and redeeming Fiat so that you might do your flight
as you would braid your Fiat with ours the creating and redeeming Fiat might be braided
by the third Fiat which is your own now one of the most astonishing things about God is his humility
why should God be humble and why would God let an ordinary creature who had been born with
original sin like everybody else and struggling to try and come to some kind of relationship with
him why would he say you do the third one to me that's beyond imagining I don't think we grasp
anything of the humility of God and I think the problem we have all the time in the spiritual life
is that the Lord is humbler than all of us and we think we're humble and our little heads have to
be pushed up and you have to recognize me you know you have got to say tanks and everything
and you've got to appreciate me and everything we don't realize that that's popping up you know
I'm important I have to be noticed and all the rest of it we don't realize that's the ego saying
excuse me but I'm not dead yet and our problem is that the king is humbler than us all that's
Paul says in Philippians chapter 2 verses 1 to 11 yeah he's the humblest yet Philippians 2
1 to 11 and Paul says yeah our mind must be like his we must start thinking like him
it's easier said than done isn't it and we keep on thinking we've done it and then a little test
and you realize no no I didn't do it yet the more you operate in our fiat the sooner you will reach
the way of our fiat and just as in the fiat of creation many prodigious and beautiful things
the whole universe came out of us and in the fiat of redemption substituted for all the acts of
creatures taking its lost child there's your Luke 15 again the prodigal son is the human race
the prodigal son is the human race taking his lost child by the hand to lead him back into the
bosom of his celestial father so will the third fiat once it has done its court let its effects
be seen that my will be known and loved and that my will take its dominion in order to have its
kingdom upon the earth each additional act of yours which you will braid with our fiat
will be a human kiss that you will have our fiat be given a greater bond that you will form
between the divine will and the human will in such a way that placed in accord it may have no reluctance
to making itself known and taking its royal dominion we have to really look at this the
lord is looking for a throne on the earth he's looking for a temple on the earth he's looking
for a place to reign on the earth and all of that is in us okay everything is in making itself known
this is terribly important the rest will come by itself this is why many times i have recommended
to you that you will meet to write nothing of what regards of my will because knowledge is the way
here you have it as clear as daylight knowledge is the way and its light serves as a trumpet
the trumpet now is the shofar the ram's horn a trumpet to call those who are listening
to make itself heard and the more the trumpet sounds it sounds more for as much more knowledge
as it has to manifest so the more people know the more the trumpet is sounding in other words
the more we study the divine will and try and take it in the more the trumpet is sounding in heaven
i'm coming i'm coming and eventually we'll hear it on the earth i want to give you a number of
references there hosea four six without knowledge the people perish jeremaia five four
proverbs 29 18 and luke 1152 so and it sounds more for as much more knowledge as it has to
be manifested the more people will rush up knowledge takes the attitude uh now of the pulpit and then
of a teacher then of a compassionate father and then of an excessive lover in other words as the
knowledge really sinks in we begin to grasp but the lord comes to us as a compassionate father
as an excessive lover as a teacher as a healer and all the rest he'll do anything to get through
to us in some it says all the ways in its power in order to enter the hearts to conquer them and
to try them in everything and the more knowledge it contains the more ways it has in its power now
because of the time i'm going to stop there and we'll take this up next week is that all right i
think that's important because we need the discipline as well